This guy, this guy is hilarious. Okay, this is actually like
pulling teeth. If hypothetically I did have these DMs, I might
be trying to not explain to people that I had these DMs because
I don't think I don't I don't want people to look into like how
or why I got these DMs or anything like that. >> Here,
the lie.
Where's the lie? >> Whiz or Whiz Smug, sorry, you both
lie. >> You both lie. Sorry, got confused. >> Whiz
lies here. I This is This is the part where he seems unimpeachable.
Unless I'm missing something. Like if I was uh like if I was
somebody with no other information, I was just tuning into this.
I'd be like, "This guy is guilty as this guy probably sent it
to everybody. This guy might have actually made the Sunday video
and hacked his channel and posted it on the channel. This is
the most guilty I've ever heard in my life." He was just arguing.
You're saying You're saying she sent it to me directly in messages.
>> He's a YouTuber that makes videos. Like that's all I
meant by commentary. YouTuber. He has commentary in his videos.
I don't really care. >> Every YouTuber is a commentary
YouTuber.
>> Sorry. What was the meaningful >> The meaningful
distinction. >> He's a drama YouTuber, isn't he? He does
a bunch of like that. >> Does some drama stuff. Yeah, does
some drama stuff. Yeah. >> Then what what was meaningful?
>> What was meaningful? Oh, you said he's a YouTuber. Does
commentary in his videos. So, he's a commentary YouTuber. I would
just say it's >> No, I'm saying the distinction, this argument
is not meaningful. It doesn't
>> Okay. All right. Sounds good. Anyway, so what was I
doing? Oh, that's why I was going to watch all the Smug Bug stuff,
though, because Aiko is now going after Smug Bug. It's got to
have more >> Calling me pedantic yesterday, whatever it
was. Oh. >> Uh, Revoke, thank you for that comment. I would
pretend that it was Kelly, but I can see you making the content.
So, thank you, Revoked, for giving Kelly an argument to make.
>> I was just agreeing with him.
>> Very base, very pog.
>> Okay. So, you're not all right.
>> Hold on. Let's go back to our joins.
>> Smug joins right here. >> So, they did a call,
a grouped call, group VC with Smug and Whiz and Perry and some
other people. They sounded very
>> Yes, they sounded so nervous. I That bug squander guy
probably sounded so nervous. I can't even imagine. You're right
on the right track, Aiko. You got it. Oh, what the [__]
Oh, that's her.
I thought that was my That's her. >> Good luck. I like
Jessica
lips that
on one second
better. >> Very very base. Very pog.
>> Okay. So you're not all right. >> Are you Well,
I can come back when you're done with that if you want. >> We're
good. So, how are you doing? How are you feeling,
>> Yeah. I mean, I'm a little bit annoyed that you leaked
all of our DMs. Like, that seemed a little bit of a >> Oh,
right. Yeah. Last night, Aiko leaked all of her DMs with Smug
Bug cuz she was asking Smug Bug about this and she was like,
"You lied to me." >> And I don't know that she knew that
Smug lied to her either, but she leaked all of her DMs with Smug
Bug last night. >> The escalation out of nowhere. Yeah,
that seems >> again Smug Bug is one of the people that
is a purported, you know, by audit right here. Wait, did we even
get to this part >> Sunday or like what the transaction
is after that? I have no idea. >> Okay. And um yeah. Okay.
Yeah, I think right here was where Let me go back. through Smug
cuz Aaron's good friends with Smug Bug. I'm >> Yeah. So
they
thought it might be Smug Bug. That's who kind of pointed the
figure at Smug Bug. So that's where it all is. All right. >> He's
a bit strange. I don't really know why he did that. >> Here
I
have a a general rule. If you lie to me in DMs, I will tell everyone.
I will >> Wait, did I raid Bad Empanada or is Bad Empanada
just in Aiko's chat? I think Bad Empanata is just in Aiko's chat.
Oh, she must be watching the abandoned panata video. Okay. >> Show
that I I have a a history of doing
>> This is how it works.
>> Okay. All right. I mean, like I don't know. If I'm If
I'm going to be friends with someone, I'd kind of expect you
to say stuff like that or tell me that you might get DMs or >> I'm
not I'm No, I'm not friends with people who lie to me either.
>> You're not Wait, so hold on. So, we've never been friends.
Like, that's funny. Oh, we're friends and I'd expect you to tell
me that. Yeah. Oh, I'm not friends with people who lie to me
either. >> I don't have to say. >> You've never been
cordial with me. You've never been like chill. You haven't You
haven't come on. No, I
>> I've had a good time. Really? >> I've enjoyed
it, >> but you've always seemed sneaky. So, I haven't trusted
you. And I'm glad that I >> Yes. I'm glad that I haven't
no li you you had you had you had a problem with us. We literally
brought you on the show to explain in detail sincerely. What
do you mean? Who cares? How did I lie to you? I didn't lie to
you about thing. I don't know what the you're talking about.
Okay. You came on our show. >> You said that.
You came on our show and I explained everything to you.
>> H I just There's something about people just yelling
over each other that just really gets my content bones going.
Okay. I I just love it. I love listening to two people who are
like angry at each other, just yell at each other. Doesn't even
have to be sensical, okay? Doesn't have to make any sense. I
don't really know. They're just yelling over each other to basically
establish the like history of their relationship. I don't know
why this couldn't be done collaboratively with like without the
yelling, but they're just screaming
>> How about we give a little context? >> How about
you ask? How about you ask How about you ask a question? How
about >> Oh my god, why does he repeat everything five
times? >> Uh, Smug Bug is infamously annoying, apparently.
I've never gotten that impression, but I think he's just kind
of like me, so I wouldn't. >> So, uh, for context, uh,
people,
uh, Smug told me Smug told me, >> "Okay, so here's what
it here's the timeline of what actually happened. So, I was talking
about the Shraider DMs. Um, I was revisiting them. uh including
the one where Sunday or Straighter Aid says to Sunday that she
sent um the uh Kyla Pixie DMs to you, Whiz, and Olive.
>> Who said this? >> Trader said this in her DM.
>> Said that she sent me DMs. >> She sent it in a
group chat with you, Whiz, and Olive.
>> Oh, let's see if Smug Bug denies these allegations.
Will he deny >> what? In the pond.
>> Okay. I don't know. I as I said, I don't I don't
>> Not good. Smug bug. She just asked you a direct question.
Literally direct question. Becket, by the way, exposed. Smug
bug. I could just confirmed. Oh, I see. Then I'm saying that
it's a direct question asked here and he just dodged it. Is it
true that? So Aaron said this. Is that true? And he's just evading.
He's not answering. He's evading >> anywhere. wasn't looking
for. >> Okay. I don't know. I as I said I >> Okay.
I don't know. He was just arguing. You're saying You're saying
she said this to me directly in messages. >> No, in like
this very specific thing. Okay. I I don't know. Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
>> Seems like people that are friends with leakers are
also leakers. It's like >> I don't know what that means,
but I do find this very funny.
>> Was heavily leaking, so the likelihood that the people
she's leaking to are trustworthy is going to be low.
Uh maybe
>> also he was friends with Ieko and uh Iiko also leaked
his DMs. So we've seen a lot of evidence for this exact friends
anymore. She doesn't cover liars. That's >> Well, we we'll
get to what the lie is. We have to figure out what happened.
Okay, that's not the lie. That's not the lie. That's not the
lie. Let me get to the lie. Let me get This is just This is the
very basic framing. >> We're not doing the lie. Okay, we're
not doing the lie. Okay. >> Why are you saying that? We're
not doing the lie. >> This is like kind of performative.
This is actually harmful. They should get a moderator if this
is how it's going to go. It's funny, but like literally she was
about to go, "That's not what the lie is. Let me explain what
the lie is." And he's like, "Oh, so we're never going to get
to the lie then. I guess I guess we're never get to the lie."
Okay. Okay. I thought we were here to discuss the lie, guys.
Yeah. Okay. Are you good? >> I'm literally giving the context
for what it is. >> Oh, that's okay. Sorry. Sorry. Now,
>> go ahead. >> This is what happens. So, so Whiz
then comes into my chat and says, "Uh, >> no, Aaron never
sent it to us." And so I DM you asking who's lying and you tell
>> what did I say? >> You said that it was group.
>> Uh, or did I say? Hang on. I think I've got it from
>> Did you literally pull these? Did you pull these out
of context, Psycho? I literally the first thing I said all of
>> Smug. Smug reviewing his DMs sounds kind of lying. >> Do
I need to Are you going to listen? >> I sent them reading
the DMs. I'm >> I am reading the DMs right now. >> The
first one out of order. >> What are you lying? I am out
of order. Convenient. Okay. So, you're setting up you're setting
up an opportunity to
calm down. You seem very mad that I said that I
>> uh can someone give me a can chat give me a TLDDR? I'll
just give you the TLDDR. So, the reason why Yeah, his mic sucks.
I know. The reason why this is coming up again is because Aaron
has started streaming and some people are mad about that. Some
people don't like that Aaron is streaming currently. Some people
are like, "Oh, she's streaming without actually addressing all
of this." Like, this is insane, right? Yeah. That's that's why
this is coming up because Aaron just started streaming again.
She's gaining some traction. She's getting viewers. Yeah. So
that's why this is coming up again. >> You we're not friends.
>> Yeah. I could Okay. How about you let me speak? Okay.
You said who is lying? I said Whiz is literally always lying.
That's it. That was the first thing I said to you. Whiz is literally
always lying. And I'm off that you've been talking to him. >> Well,
that's like a meme in general. That doesn't sound like an actual
answer >> about my behind my back. He's been he's just
been behind my back. And look, I get I get that you have a funny
on the >> I've barely spoken to Whiz. >> I've barely
spoken to Whiz. I don't want to pull all of my DMs with Whiz
right >> Show the DM. >> I'll show the DM all of
my DMs with
all of them. >> Show the DMs with me that you excluded.
I'm sending you a screenshot. Pull the screenshot
stream if you're not. >> I will. >> These are from
our DMs. Why has no one seen these? Why is no one seeing me saying
the truth, which is that Whiz is always [__] liar.
>> Talking about I did send >> I literally just sent
you a screenshot, I just sent you the screenshot, I
>> So he's accusing Whiz of being a liar, but then Becket
just tells him it was Smug Bug. Anyway, >> um Well,
so I haven't I haven't seen So Becket said something about Smug
Bug. Yes. But I don't know if there was proof that it was Smug
Bug here. The proof is I think Aaron says she sent it in a group
chat with three other people, >> So this would be who gave
the DMs to
>> Maybe he says maybe he says Smug Bug directly, but I
didn't I didn't get that impression. We'll have to see exactly
how the production >> Hold on. Let me pull it up. Jesus,
>> please calm yourself. Okay, let's see.
>> Weird that this didn't end up in the leaks. The one
part that doesn't suit your I sent you a screenshot. >> Okay.
Why? >> By that logic, nobody should ever address anything.
And then what do we do for content? Um, soapbox, I think this
is like trying to clarify when the people who are broadly accusing
you of something wrong are like not good not good faith actors.
Like they're not they're not attempting to like do right, they
hate you and are trying to destroy you, right? The people who
are like who are trying to like actually listen and understand,
for the most part, those people aren't going to have the positions
they have that are like totally ignoring a bunch of evidence.
I'm not even talking about you, Kelly. talking about in general
like usually the thought would be oh there's evidence like against
this entire idea in public but the people who are criticizing
me aren't actually looking at that evidence they're explicitly
ignoring it. So a further clarification for me actually isn't
going to help because they're going to like literally just be
super gross about that too. So you could just you make that calculation
every time you know reveal something >> if you're talking
about an audience. Sure. But Io liked this guy. They were friendly
at least and Aiko liked Straighter Aid and President Sunday and
Aiko like Straighter Aid. So I I don't think that's anything
to do with like disliking people. It's not coming from like a
super hateful place. If anything, you'd have to like care and
like about the other person to want to like confront them. I
believe in this kind of >> Maybe
we'll see. We'll see as we go. >> This is not Why is this
not working? >> Sorry. I Sorry. OBS rocket science happening
right now. Yeah. Pull it up on stream. Take however long it needs.
>> I keep it. >> What a catty [__] What
the mean? >> I mean, I straight up because I watched her
last stream that Jessica didn't know what I was talking about
when she came on stream. I I straight up says I liked Aaron
more so than other people involved in this. I like straight raid
too. So,
>> This is weird. I think probably if you like someone
it is it's gonna be come across as more critical because you
have a higher standard for them. >> Everyone actually loves
and and they all think she's a duplicitous
who literally is totally morally bankrupt. But we do like her
but like she's a duplicitous [__] with no moral character
whatsoever. But I like her. >> Okay. Would you be No. This
is where it started as people liked. Are you more critical of
someone that does something that you liked and respected or are
you more critical of someone that you always thought was a piece
of of course it's going to hit different when it's someone you
like >> of the context >> cuz that also makes you
uh question your own judgment on things and that makes everyone
mad. So like yeah you're going to be a bit >> sure you
can give you can give your criticism and again I think the issue
for me is that the the reaction or the criticisms are like baked
in. She's like, I don't think I'll change them, right? So that's
why there's just no point to me. But it's fine. >> It's
like I go out of my way tormenting Destiny because I knew him
for long enough that the disappointment is like insurmountable.
If I didn't know the guy very well, I wouldn't be like bothering
him still at this point.
>> I'd be like, "Oh, yes. It's a piece of
>> Sure. Sure.
>> Okay, we continue. Not this one. This
Oh, she's doing OBS stuff. Hold on.
>> Here we go. >> Here we go. Here we go.
>> Okay, let me move you.
>> Okay. I said Aaron said on stream. >> Yes. I said
Aaron said she sent the DMs to you, Whiz, and Olive. Whiz said
she did not. Who is lying?
Smug says Whiz is literally always lying. I have no idea who's
probably doing a bit. Becca did read this actually.
>> Okay, so this is pretty explicitly
um that's not true. If any reading of this other than that's
not true could only be if if it was so if Aaron really said this
either Aaron is lying or Smug Bug is like lying by extension,
right? Cuz like he could argue, well technically she sent it
to a channel, technically she sent it to like us those three
plus one and but it's like that's just an evasion. this a total
evasion that I think it's probably clear that one of them has
to be lying. Either Aaron if she said this directly or Smug if
Smug said this directly. I want to see Can I see the Sunday DM?
Does Can anybody find that for me? The Sunday DM where straight
raid says I sent it to these people as well. I'd love to see
that if we got it. >> Okay. I didn't >> if someone
got I don't understand why this is one screenshot.
>> What are you talking about? You say this kind of all
the time. He's your >> co. You know what? I'm going to
be Io. I'm going to be
Io. I'm going to be I'm going to be super charitable with you.
I'm going to be super charitable. I'm going to imagine that somehow
these DMs ended up out of order and you didn't real and and I
guess it got split at a very inconvenient place for your
one for your nar size of the screen. >> So why why have
you not brought this up? >> Everything everything was there.
Becket just got one out of order. That's it. cuz I sent him all
of it. >> Okay. Well, it's unfortunate that that mistake
seems to have lined up very nicely with your narrative. Okay.
Cuz I said the first thing I told you is that is lying. >> Saying
that Whiz is li Okay. So then what are you supposed to do with
that? How about you saying that Becket sent it to you? >> I'm
the one who has to live with it. >> How about you saying
that Becket sent it to you? >> When did I say Becket? What
did Beck Oh, sorry. What did I say? >> You got it from
the Pixie uh Kyla DMs. You said, "Let me pull." >> What
did I get from the Yeah. Yeah, pull up pull up the I'll pull
up your stream. Let me see what's you've got here. >> Let's
see. >> I mean, I'm scrolling. I'm sorry. Just give me
the thing. I can control F it. >> I don't unless you've
deleted. >> I just messaged Becca to say like, "Hey, do
you actually did you actually get these screenshots directly
from Smug Bug?" That seems like a nice tidy question that I still
don't have a clear answer to.
>> Ah, is it something from the DMs? >> I've literally
not deleted anything.
I'm just I'm just asking. I'm just also
>> Okay. Go to Hold on. I have a lot has happened. So,
I have a lot of
>> Yeah. Okay. A lot has happened. Okay. >> He's
so He's so catty. It's very funny. >> What? Okay. Wait.
What are What am I looking for? Oh, Becket. >> You You
What do you mean? Okay. Jesus >> Listen, I wasn't planning
on trying.
>> Wait, seriously? Hell >> hush. You're fine. You
know, I'm not surprised at how sloppy this all is. >> It's
not fine. This is lame, brother. >> Dude, he's he's >> If
I was uh like if I was somebody with no other information, I
was just tuning into this. I'd be like, "This guy is guilty as
this guy's probably sent to everybody. This guy might have actually
made the Sunday video and hacked his channel and posted it on
the channel. This is the most guilty I've ever heard in my life."
>> Like, I I don't know why he's going he's going off so
hard. This is embarrassing.
for you. Maybe >> I come on I come on for two minutes and
your narrative collapses instantly.
>> What? Oh, he's saying that Whiz is just
>> Wait, no, that wouldn't be Whiz just lying. That would
be Aaron also lying. Sorry. Sorry. That would be one of Oh, I'm
No, no, no, no, no. It'd be Whiz lying saying she did not. Oh,
then you got sent them then. Okay. How did Who Where did it leak
from you guys? Wait, Whiz is just lying.
Oh, yeah. So, that's just admitting that he did get the DMs.
Okay, but he then then Aiko goes to Oh, Jesus. Sorry. I'm a little
slow today. Then Aiko goes to Well, you told me you didn't get
them. They they weren't sent to you. So, wait, what? This is
you admitting you lied to me. Okay, easy. >> Did you not
say that you got it from quote unquote Beckett's area? Hold on.
Wait, let me I'm looking. >> This is confusing because
now this is her DMs with Smug directly. So, it doesn't seem like
Smug told her I didn't get the DMs at all. >> Becket's
area. Yeah, absolutely. >> What does Beckett's area mean?
>> I'm not going to elaborate on that.
>> Okay. Me. >> What? Wait, what? >> Let me
say that you got it from quote unquote Beckett's area. Hold on.
Wait. Let me let I'm looking for >> Beck's area. Yeah,
absolutely. >> What does Beckett's area mean? >> I'm
not going to elaborate on that. I got it from Becket's area.
What does that mean? I don't know what
next.
>> Let me go to the other one where you say >> Yeah.
Unlike you guys, I actually actually about people and I'm not
going to blow up other people's spot. Yeah, I do. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
That's you leaks DMs the second you can get 20. >> Guy
likes to dig his own grave. Clearly, >> I The funny thing
is is annoying as he is and as guilty as he sounds, I tend to
think this is possibly true. Um I wouldn't say I go doesn't care.
I would just say that people don't have the whole picture or
something. That's very likely what's going on here. People just
don't have like a full picture. They're trying to >> That's
what happens when someone doesn't
six months
>> again and again and again. I'll just keep saying that
Strader would not be able to provide the full picture. All of
Strader's contributions here are accounted for, but it's fine
cuz I I can't I can't say it again. So, you're running through
a six-month old drama again for no reason. >> Does anyone
else believe that
it or is it just me that's what I say about Whiz? He's a [__]
Hold on. Wait. Why? Why did you just link me something from Why
did you just link me something from Becket covering my [__]
Did Becket leak these DMs? Will he cover my Hold on. What is
this? Hold on. Hold on. This is about me and
Where's Where's Smug mentioned here? You link me something that
where it is this. You will see
>> we had >> Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. Did you link a time stamp? Oh, you didn't link a time stamp.
Extoay, did Portortoella link a time stamp? >> I rules.
Good evening. >> Oh, right here. Smug and say your >> Well,
I have Yeah, I have many. What did Smug and W say? >> So,
here's the video. >> 54 minutes.
>> Oh, 5. Oh, that's why it didn't work. I see. Hold on.
Here we go. That's why it didn't work for me. >> Oh. Oh.
Oh. Am I the story now? Can I be the story now? I wasn't in pond.
I can tell you all I know. >> We do need We do need this.
This is good. Important part of the story. Thank >> Becket's
area
who I can't remember who into thinking that he had way more than
he did. And then Becca, I think, just followed his lead because
he's weak. Okay, so Erin lied when she said she only showed it
to you and Wiz and Olive. That's super special info I have. Didn't
she show it to Sunday? Isn't that how it leaked? That was obviously.
You lying little [__] rat bug. >> I can. >> Okay,
so is this him? Is he really going to say this? >> You
are a lying rat. You had these DMs. Uh-oh. You had these DMs.
>> Uh-oh.
Actually,
>> wait. Hold on. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Did he say he doesn't have
the DMs here? Wait. Where does he say he doesn't have the DMs?
Wait. Why does >> aren't you autistic? Why do you think
you'd have the right take on someone socially? That's like >> permanently
banned for permanently banned. Good luck. Fill out a a form or
something. Fill out a form. You want to come in here and just
attack for no reason while I'm trying to do actual content on
this trying to follow a line of like thinking. You get out of
here forever. Bye.
Anyway,
I can't say. So, Becket is saying, "Youly little liar. You disgusting.
You disgusting lying bug." Okay. What? Why are you saying you
didn't have the DMs? Where does he say he doesn't have the DMs?
I actually don't see it here. I It also might be here. I've been
really interesting. Oh, am I the story now? Can I be the story
now? It wasn't in the pond. I can tell you all I know, which
has nothing to do with the pond and was entirely based on me
being buddies with Becket's area. Sunday gas lit someone, I can't
remember who, into thinking that they he had way more than he
did. And then Becket, I think, just followed his lead because
he's weak. Okay, so Aaron lied when she said she only showed
it to you, you, Whiz, and Olive. That's some super special info
I have. Didn't she show it to Sunday? And isn't that how it leaked?
That was obviously he's not denying anywhere here from what I
can see that he has these screenshots that he has these logs.
>> Oh, cool.
>> This is completely ret. Okay, I'll I'll not perma that
guy. I will cut him down to a day. He's out for the day. I'll
unperma. I'll >> It's not like I have a back and forth
is just answering your question. >> I know. Kind of dumb.
>> Oh, in the middle of me reading DMs, which is kind of
annoying, but it's >> Oh, DMs everyone's already seen that
we can all see on the bloody screen. Oh, no. I um I'll I'm just
going to collect them and send them to you. Okay.
>> Yeah. We're not honoring redeems right >> Now,
the pond isn't involved in anything
>> like bro. >> Okay. That cuz thing as well. >> Probably
alive. >> Those DMs had bug spread around to Whiz. I don't
know if you people know who Wiz is, but he's like IRL live friends
with loner box. >> Oh, that would be awkward. M
Oh, that makes sense actually cuz did you see their coverage
of the Destiny stuff in general? >> No, I didn't call.
>> They did uh
they um it wasn't even about Destiny. They like equated it to
this G. >> Wait, I think they Hold on. One, that's a funny
meme. So, when they did the pon the the Ponum podcast, the little
podcast they do together, right? They did a bit where they were
just reviewing like a Destiny 2 drama, but their title was like
Destiny going down forever. It was like a whole meme where they
did a bait and switch and then they charged $100 to do the actual
Destiny drama coverage. That was like I'm I assume they got to
it eventually and they were just memeing for the first part of
the show waiting to get up to their like donation goal. Anyway,
oh maybe they didn't comment on it at all. >> Game Destiny
>> thought it was a bit tasteless and annoying. Why? That's
literally their show. That's literally their show is they do
these like gay little puppet shows. They do their gay little
bits which I actually kind of like. I I kind of like like the
idea of doing the bits with OBS and stuff. It's pretty cool.
But uh most people just say gay little bits. Okay. They do their
their little bits and that's a whole thing they do. It's like
a whole subversion podcast. I don't know. That's that's how I
see it most of the time. But anyway, >> maybe or some something
like that. They talked in like code. It was It was
>> where do we get to the next thing?
>> Yeah. Go on. Yeah. Yeah. >> Okay. Sunday comes
on >> and he's going to clear some things up. >> Okay.
Can I bring these up on stream? >> Can I bring these up
on stream? >> Go for it. I don't even know what's in there.
I didn't look.
>> this is, by the way, Sunday does this all of the time.
Sunday infamously,
actually, I probably shouldn't even say. Sunday does this all
the time with his DMs and leaks things he's not supposed to leak
all the time. It's very funny for him to just show up and be
like, I didn't even read these. Just go. It's like, dude, you
should read them. You have no idea. If you actually have no idea
what's in here, that's crazy. >> It's okay. Me, too. I
knew you were my president. So, you're going to let me in. So,
what? You already have all the juice? VC smug, I'm not a drama
guy. I don't care. My darling wife is fast asleep. Lol. Okay.
Smug, don't seem like the worst stuff leaked. It'll probably
be fine. I know you're on max damage uh kick. I respect her.
Present Sunday. What's the worst stuff? Smug bug. I am against
my will on the stop the girl loudly self- emilating kick. Sorry,
bro. I never leak. I will never I will not be useful to you.
Sunday, I'm not the one who leaked is the thing. Smoke bug. You
came to me for it personally. Yeah, it doesn't suit you. I think
I know. >> You No, you come to me for my personality. Yeah,
it doesn't suit you. I think I know that. >> It's probably
fine.
>> So, Smokef is referencing the worst episode. So, he
definitely had leaks, claiming he had potentially more leak than
Sunday does. Bro, what are you doing? Just own your position
and shut the up. I'm so annoyed. Wait, is he not owning his Am
I confused? Am I the only one who's confused here? Cuz I swear
to God, the smug guy is saying, "Yeah, um like I literally I
have the leaks, but I'm not going to leak them to you. Sorry."
He's literally saying he has them, but I don't want to I I'm
against my will. Uh so I am against my will on the stop the girl
loudly self- emilating kick as in I'm trying to help her despite
what's going on. Right. So I'm not going to leak to you. Sorry.
Better luck next time is what he says to Sunday. That's like
not even really confusing here. >> Actually, these are
all voluntary. Like Whiz comes into chat and he's like, "I didn't
know anything. We didn't see anything." Like, you didn't even
have to say anything. >> Yeah. And but what did Smug Bug
say about that? He said Whiz is lying. I >> bro. This is
why this is [__] like this is unironically why the
videos were made. Like ironically, because one thing that Sunday
night converation was like, I don't have to dance until they
come out really like we've hit like that. We know the music say.
And then you see stuff like this of just how people are. Come
bug, shut up. You knew. It's okay that you knew. It's fine. I'm
just more annoyed that you're now trying to pass the buck off
like Sunday and I were with the only ones who had anything. You're
just like super innocent. We're all shocked and you knew. >> Can
somebody find me that? Where did Becket form this opinion from?
Cuz as far as I can tell, SmugMug has never been like koi about
having them, right? Well, he said he said, "I don't understand
what Whiz is saying." That's all he said. He's not saying I know
nothing about nothing. He literally says Whiz is lying. As in,
I Yeah, that did happen. And but I don't know anything about
why he's lying. >> You You played the information game.
>> Yeah. Also, they do seem to think that uh everybody
knows and I didn't know. I know Quean didn't know. That's actually
the only two I know didn't know even up till like the day before.
I was super cuz Queen got brought into the circle of trust like
I think a day before or something and I was like, "Bro, what
the happening? Why? What?" Cuz somebody came on and made some
gay reference about it. But I didn't know at all. That's why
when Sunday was on here, he's like, "You knew everything you
needed to know." I'm like, "Dude, you had way more information
than me like the whole time. I don't know what you're talking
about." >> Whiz knew you played the information game. Shut
up. You are absolutely drama guys. Like this whole cope about
we're just normies. We're not really involved. Uh bro, the so
if anything, does this make this worse for Eron potentially?
Wait, did Eron give more stuff to them? >> Who knows? Like
there
Smug is an unserious like disturb. So it's possible he was just
I have no idea. I don't think so. I don't think really I don't
think anyone in this conversation really >> No, but it
matters. It matters from the perspective that like it's clearly
trying to throw you and me under the bus as opposed >> I
don't disagree. It's just I don't think I don't think they I
don't think they have a bus. I don't think they have the arms
to throw us. And I think I think it's just >> No, I'm just
annoyed. I'm just annoyed that they >> Yeah, I hear you.
Don't get me wrong. >> Well, I'm just like, bro, >> [__]
shut up.
>> I don't Wait, was Smug talking about this?
Where was Smug talking? I feel like other people are digging
into Smug and he's like answering questions. I don't even know.
I know everybody else involved here way more than Smug Bug, by
the way. I'm just like reading the DMs and interpreting. >> Wait,
hold on. I I also want to say in that in that DM that uh I sent
where where she was saying that it's contained to Smug Wiz and
Olive. Um what she says >> Okay, I don't think we need
more here unless there's like more DMs that come through. We're
going to see if the scan changes. Scan same. Scan same.
Go to this. Whiz said she didn't send them. Oh, right here. Uh
it's contained to you, Smug, Whiz, and Olive. Okay, so I Whiz
said she didn't send them and that she's lying. Who is lying?
Smug, pick one to sacrifice. He literally responded to this in
the DMs that we have on this stream. Whiz is literally lying.
Literally always lying. I have no idea. He was probably doing
a bit as in Yeah, he was Whiz was lying. Aaron was telling the
truth. Whiz was lying. Nippling.
>> Why do you have a show with him? >> Because it's
good content. In the same way that you do, you probably I I hope
you don't I hope you're not morally okay with what you're doing
right now because
someone lies. >> Disgusting. Someone. Okay. You shouldn't
have lied to me. >> Where have I lied to you? I literally
said Whiz is the one lying. I don't know why you think I said.
>> I lio. Where's the lie? >> Whiz or Whiz? Smug.
Sorry. You both lie. >> You both lie. Sorry. Got confused.
>> Lies. How do
this? >> You said as in >> I This is This is the
part where he seems unimpeachable. Unless I'm missing something.
Like literally I goes like 40 chess here is one has to be lying.
Whiz or straight raid. And he goes Whiz is lying. Whiz is lying.
As in I had those DMs. Whiz is lying. And she's like ha well
I've proven that you said you didn't have the DMs. Who? It seems
like you're lying to me. I'm going to leak all of your DMs. What
is happening? >> And this is months ago and I wasn't involved.
Yeah. Via Beckett. I think my only involvement was trying to
get Becket to send. >> Now Now here's the thing where he
might be lying. Okay. As in this was months ago. I wasn't involved.
Yeah, via Beckett, I think. Did you see them before Sunday's
video? Yeah, via Becket. I think
that is the one where Okay, now he's trying to throw Becket under
the bus a little bit here. That might be wrong. Okay, that might
be totally wrong.
I think cuz I It seems like unless he's arguing that he knew
about them via Becket before he knew about them via straight
raid, which I don't believe would be the case. >> [__]
Because I thought it was gross. >> Okay. Wait, so as Becket
said something different that I wasn't because that was my only
my only association with this entire thing was I thought it was
really gross for Becket and Sunday to throw a girl's
note into a video and so I told them to censor it and then I
think they did. I I didn't end up following up. I just said
sorry. So how did this happen after the videos came out? If Beckett
started off censored, he said that you reached out to Jenny or
one of you you or Whiz
Jenny. Wait, Becket Becket said that. What did Becket say about
>> that? Uh, I think you or Whiz reached out to Jenny about
censoring the um the >> Yeah, I'm not going to I'm not
going to Yeah, I'm not speak >> Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on.
>> you said that because you'd already seen the DMs and
that's >> Yeah, that's what I was thinking here is like
I think so if if I'm guessing what Smug Bug was doing here is
he was going well I did see them via Becket as well as in Becket
like probably talked to him about them and so he's like trying
to cast like suspicion away from himself in like straight raid
and stuff and trying to go like well I also got them like I also
smug Smug has answered questions that's just wrong but also it's
very funny that he's trying to go like, well, I want to offiscate
where I actually saw these from originally and so I'm going to
kind of like speak around the truth a little bit, but when he
was asked and it specifically came up like straight said this,
Whiz said this, he was like, "No, Straight is telling the truth.
Whiz is lying." It's true because the reason that my video was
like privated and that was censored is because Smug Bug said
that to Jenny.
>> Smug Bug was like, "I can't believe that Becket is is
showing these on stream. He needs to send this." and Jenny didn't
have the DMs >> and I never showed them to Smug Bug because
there's no there's no communication between me and >> Okay,
hold on. I think Aiko is misunderstanding here. I She's possibly
misunderstanding. Smug Bug clearly had more information on what
was in the DMs. Said it's gross that this is being shown uncensored,
right? That's a different thing than saying um Oh, that's a different
thing than saying that somebody reached out to Jenny and gave
them the DMs, which I think is kind of what Haiko is saying here.
>> wait. Becket Becket said that what did Becket say about
>> that? Uh I think you or Whiz reached out to Jenny about
censoring the um the
>> Yeah. If Becket wants to if Becket wants to be he can
you can go to him for info. I'm not I'm not saying any more on
that. That's fine. >> Okay. Well, what I what I'm saying
is if you No, actually because this is the time the time >> No,
I'm skipping. You can say what you
>> dude. Skip. Next. Dude, this guy just came on and he
runs show now. No. Next. Next question. Nope. Skip. Skip. Nope.
Skip. Next question. Next question. >> So,
you're saying that you you did this, but how could you possibly
um have have gotten What are you doing? Why are you making weird
noises? >> Oh, I was literally just drinking some water.
Sorry. Okay. Jesus. >> Okay. So, how exactly? >> Speaking
of which, I'm going to go get a drink. Be right back. >> Um,
ask Becket to do this be after his video when he had uh blurted
out before before it was released. >> Yep. I didn't I didn't
ask Becket. >> You You didn't. Now you didn't. >> Yeah.
I I think I think I
Jenny, you always do this. You're so
>> Yeah. This is I can see exactly who this guy is. If
you formulate a question that can be answered like no to on the
most pedantic of grounds, he will say no because he can, right?
I can tell everything about this guy. Like he will and probably
to his like detriment. Like literally you could just be more
honest here and it would make everybody way less suspicious of
you. But he like he sees that he could say no technically in
a very technical sense and he's like no I didn't I didn't get
I didn't ask that. I didn't talk to Becket, right? Like you know
what she said words. How am I Weasly?
You're the one who's literally Sorry. You literally misrepresented
our entire DMs and you're calling me Weasly. I'm literally answering
every question unless I think that it's a >> Also, I'm
grabbing water using the bathroom really quickly. Sorry, I I'll
be right back. But I will I'll listen and I'll analyze anything
I miss. I'll be right back.
>> You're the one who's literally Sorry. You literally
misrepresented our entire DMs and you're calling me Weasley.
I'm literally answering every question unless I think that it's
>> Okay. So you asked Jenny, you talked to Jenny about
blurring this and stuff. >> Carry on. >> Okay. Yeah.
So how So you did that before the video came out because when
the video came out, it didn't have this. >> Okay. Land
the plane. >> What are you trying to do here? >> I'm
trying to I'm trying to get you to ask your question. I'm waiting.
>> I just don't Okay, so you're saying, >> "Hey,
I'm back. I had to pause just a second early there cuz I um or
pause because I want to comment on this." I think the main the
main issue right here
is that um the main issue here is that I think the misunderstanding
is that Ieko believes Smug Bugs denied having these DMs and I
do not believe he has like categorically denied having these
DMs
And that's Iiko's like I got you because you're you're you're
like admitting that you messaged Jenny and Becket says you messaged
Jenny before you even saw stuff, right? Uh Demier, sure. Maybe
maybe that's happening. So before Yeah. So I I talked to Jenny
or something. Rebecca's saying that he talked to Jenny and it
kind of proves that he's seen the DMs beforehand, but he's not
even denying that he saw the DMs beforehand.
That's like So So Aiko is like, "I just landed the plane. I just
proved that you're lying." And Smug Bug's like, "Wait, are you
aren't you going to say something?" Like he he doesn't even understand
that she thinks she's got him. And he sat here and like never
denied having the DMs.
Okay, >> to be clear, if I listen, I here's here's my proposal
to you. If you he also I think he knows actually I think he knows
what direction she's trying to go in, but he doesn't want to
give her anything. So now he's going to be like, "Well, you here's
how you now he's going to be like, well, I'll throw you a little
morsel and explain to you like I haven't watched this, by the
way." I feel like he might do something like, "Well, here here's
what I'll say." If hypothetically I did have these DMs, I might
be trying to not explain to people that I had these DMs because
I don't think I don't I don't want people to look into like how
or why I got these DMs or anything like that. Hypothetic. He
might do something like that here. We'll see. >> Actually
care and this isn't just about content and you genuinely have
a moral care. Then why don't you ask Becket? DM >> What
are you talking about? He'll clear it up for you. >> He
literally told me on We talked about it in the the video. I guess
you weren't paying attention to because the video I just premiered.
We literally talked about it. Yes. He's the one that He told
me all these things during the the stream. He told me that you
went to Jenny about this stuff because you thought it should
be blurred out. So, he blurred it out. No one cares that you
had this before. No one cares. And I never would have asked.
It's just because of Whiz coming in and saying that uh Aaron
didn't send it to you guys. I asked you and you said that you
got it because of being in Beckett's area or via Beckett and
that turned out to not be >> that is that is a lie. >> Becket's
area. >> Well, hold on. Becket's area. Becket's area being
like somebody in all of Twitch poll. Okay. Twitch pole andor
or art commentary. Becket's area as in this person has a YouTube
channel registered.
>> What's Becket's area mean? And you gave it to Kilo.
>> Ask Becket. Ask Becket. I gave Wait, sorry. What did
I give to? I don't even >> Apparently, you gave it to Kilo.
Supposedly, that's that's the thing that people said. >> Uh,
that's a thing. Sorry. That's what stands for journalistic integrity.
Kilo. Sorry. Get Kilo here. Kilo said I gave Kilo [__]
>> Journalistic integrity. >> What are you talking
about? >> What the are you What am I talking about? What
do you mean? I'm I thought you supposed to do this morally. You're
saying this is Kilo says that is not what I said. >> This
we just do it for content. My issue is if you lie if you lie
kilo in chat I never said that. Wait, who lied to you? Like I
kilo just said that he never said that. What the
>> Oh wow. Oh, sorry. You mean the two guys who released
video a video of a of all of these leagues, right? The guys who
actually leaked this publicly. Why is he actually so loud? I
don't know. Hold on. I can EQ this a little bit. Give me a second.
I'll try to EQ this. Uh uh. Where's my EQ thing?
lied to you and didn't have anyone's best interest at heart.
You're idiot. I go I was doing nothing. I just thought I just
thought it was to put a girl in a video. That was my one involved.
>> Okay, I I eueded it. It should be okay, I think. Right.
Is this Is this good? Is this better? >> It was cringe.
You should not do that. That is basic. I don't think you have
a single moral. I think you just want a bit of content. You This
is embarrassing. Go talk to Becket and Sunday and see if their
stories square up because Kilo's just told you that they lied
to you. Embarrassing. Jesus >> I don't care about Kilo.
I'm just me. >> I don't think anybody lied here. I think
probably it's just misunderstandings
>> The truth. You actually don't care about the truth.
This is so weak.
Sorry. You have not been able to prove that I lied. You've just
shown that you lied or just represented someone else's lie uncritically.
You said that I gave to Kilo when I didn't. Kilo just came here
and said I didn't. >> You just lied. Daiko.
>> I think she'd probably just miss. Bro, this guy This
guy knows how to press. Okay. W Press.
He He He's got an inch of daylight and he's taking it right now.
>> I threw that. >> You're a liar. I You're a liar.
>> You just lied. >> You want to calm down? >> You
just lied. Do you want to admit it? Do you want to admit you
were wrong? Do you want to admit you were wrong about Kilo? Do
you want to admit you were wrong about Kilo? Do you want to admit
you were wrong? I I said I'm wrong. Yeah, I'm wrong about Kilo.
Sure. If you >> This guy is like uh bizarre world pisco.
Did you lie? Yes or no? You So when you said that, you lied,
right? Yes or no? Yes or no? Did you lie? Yes or no? Did you
lie? It's like it does not as effective when he does it, but
he is doing it a little bit. >> You got to admit it. Hold
on. >> Do you want to admit it? Do you want to >> You
just lied. >> You want to calm down? >> You just
lied. Do you want to admit it? Do you want to admit you were
wrong? Do you want to admit you were wrong about Kilo? Do you
want to admit you were wrong about Kilo? Do you want to admit
you were wrong? I I said well giving me brain damage repeating
his words this >> Do you want to admit you were wrong is
different than did you lie? So there you go. Yeah, I'm wrong
about Kilo. Sure. If >> you want to admit you're wrong
about that about me saying do you want to admit you were wrong
about Whiz being being the liar? Cuz I said that too.
>> Whiz if Whiz is a liar then he's a freak. Then he's
a freak. I don't know what to tell you. You had two You've had
two lies. Two things that you thought were right that completely
wrong. >> Then why did you say that you got it from via
Beckett?
that brain freeze right there is so
He just That was like a full at two to three seconds of silence
right there at least, wasn't it? Hold on. That might be >> Why
did you say that you got it from via Beckett? 1 100 2 100 3 100
4 100 5 100 6 100 7 100 8 100 9 100
11 100 13 100 14 100 15 100 His mic must have disconnected or
he lagged out. There's no way he
>> I'm not going to say anything.
>> Okay. Smug bug one. Smug bug one. Smug bug one. Smug
Bug won. >> He didn't even the answer to that.
>> Smug Bug won completely. He's just like, it didn't come
through. He just said no. He said skip. >> Skip. Skip.
Next question. >> I I I can absolutely.
>> I did ask Becket. I talked to Becket. I talked to Becket.
>> And he said that didn't happen. He said we didn't have
them until like the 17th or something. He had it. He saw it like
last.
Okay. So you Why did you say Beckett? It was not Becket. So why
did you say Becket? >> Skip. Say it. Say it. >> The
only involvement I had in this was saying that he shouldn't add
the Oh, wait. Did my mic just cut out? >> The only involvement
The only involvement I had was Beckett
not putting in that note. That's it. That's all it was on the
day. >> He said via you saw it. >> He if he was being
honest here, he would say, "I was trying to misdirect from who
actually leaked it to me cuz I didn't want to be honest about
it cuz I like that person or something." That's what he would
say, right? That's why he said via Beckett's area cuz it was
super super ultra vague, right? >> Via Beckett. You said
you saw the Kyla Pixie DMs via Beckett. You say that here. Is
that untrue?
>> Can you show me those DMs? >> It's on the screen
now. >> You're trying to prove >> Oh, he does. Wait.
Oh, hold on. Actually, Becket's area. Beckett's area is what
he said. What he typed was, "Yeah, via Beckett." I think he's
going to go, "Well, I didn't really remember, guys. I think.
Did you see them before Sunday's video? >> Wait, hold on
a second. >> No, thanks.
>> I should be making friends with any of these people.
>> Can you see? >> Did you see them before Sunday's
video? I think that's just an unclear them. I The stuff that
I saw,
Oh, this is this guy is funny as I'm sorry. This would be infuriating
to deal with in person, but this is actually so funny to watch.
>> It's so funny. >> I'm sorry. >> I literally
right before
send what context, please. The Pixie Kyla DM. Send them to who?
>> This guy's one level below Jordan Peterson here. Well,
that just depends on what the meaning of is is actually. He's
right there. He's right there. >> Uh, Sunday Aaron said
she sent the DMs to you, Whiz, and Olive. Whiz said she did not.
Who is lying? You say Whiz is literally always lying. I have
no idea. He was probably doing a bit.
Okay. Did Aaron send it to you? The scirly thing Sunday had?
No. >> Dude, you can see how Weasly he's being in real
time. It's so funny. This is so insanely Weasly. I was in a VC
yesterday and somebody told me that the exact quote was, "Smug
moves in the weirdest way, so I'm not surprised people are suspicious
of him." And now I know exactly what this means. Like this guy
speaks and he just like obfiscates all the time like as a reflex
or something like this is this is super funny. Did I get the
exact video that Sunday had in his No, I didn't get that. I didn't
I didn't get that. No, >> I say or screenshot.
I don't think so. >> Did he say I didn't hear him ever
say that Whiz wasn't lying. Spudgun I as far as I can tell he
said Whiz was lying the whole time. So he's got that for I now
I'm just shocked that he said that outright. I'm shocked he didn't
say well whiz says things. I'm I'm shocked that that wasn't his
response. >> Oh, what do you mean I don't think so? What's
the case you're trying to prove? Maybe I can help. This is all
within Oh, I took these at separate times. >> Never mind.
>> Wait, what? Okay, hold on. What you What you trying
to Okay, so if you if you meant generally, then I saw I saw the
on the day of the video releases. Yeah. >> You didn't see
the Kyle PC DMs before the video release? >> No, I I did.
That's why I complained about it on the day. >> You said
that you saw it, >> dude. This That's why like you shouldn't
just max obfiscate all the time cuz now he's like he doesn't
even know. He's not differentiating between what's important.
He doesn't It's probably revealing that he's he's not ready to
have this conversation cuz he's not understanding like what he
should be protecting, what's important. So now he's like, "No,
no, no. I totally did. Why? How else could I have set that video?"
And I go out under the impression that he's still not really
admitted this at all. >> Via Beckett.
>> Oh, sorry. Sorry, the via Becket. No, she does know
that. It's via Beckett is the important part. True. >> She
didn't send it to me. Becket did.
>> Aaron never sent me any of that. >> She never
put it in a group chat that had had you. >> So, I'm guessing
the answer is here. Okay. Is it was sent to one of those three
people that were named and then it was sent to Smug Bug with
like Aaron's blessing or something like, "Hey, Aaron, I want
to share it with this person. Do you mind if I share it with
this person alone?" By the way, the answer that to that should
always be no. No, no. Cuz if you trust somebody with some information,
it has to be like to the grave. You promise me you won't share
it with anybody, even your most trusted people. Because everybody
does this thing where they have like a trusted circle of like
one, two, three people that they'll share things with that they
think will will never come out. That's exactly how everything
like this ever leaks, right? You have like this trusted circle
of people. They'll never ever leak your stuff ever. You trust
them with your life and then the friendship like breaks apart
and then suddenly that is out in the open, right? But also those
three people have three people they trust implicitly
all the time will never ever doubt them. And those three people
the what nine people downstream of those three people all have
another three. And it's like it just keeps going right. It just
keeps going forever and ever and ever. And that's exactly how
this happens. I don't >> probably the first person who
was entrusted with stuff should have just not shared anything.
>> Yeah, I would agree. They have the primary responsibility.
Absolutely. group chat I've ever been in. That is ridiculous.
I think they would remember who sent me those DMs. >> I
Okay, I >> Why did you say Becket? Did you really believe
that you got it through Becket? Do you believe that you received
them through Becket? >> Received what? I Okay,
dude. Is this like pulling teeth? This guy This guy is hilarious.
Okay, this is actually like pulling teeth. It's so funny. Kyla
Pixy DMs. The Kyla Pixy DMs. Did you see them? >> So, Smug
isn't like lying. You can tell by how badly he's obiscating and
where he does it that like he's actually not lying. He's trying
to not talk about it cuz he doesn't he doesn't feel comfortable
talking about it, right? So, he's trying to say like, "Did you
are you sure you received them via Becket?" He knows that's not
true. He's trying to like cast doubt away from like how he received
them in the first place, right? Or cast like suspicion away from
how he received them in the first place. And so, yes, now he's
going like, "Well, it depends on what you mean by those. It means
what do you mean? Did I did I see them? What do you mean by them?
How many more skips does he have?" He probably should have just
skipped the whole thing would have helped him a lot cuz I think
his his like hesitancy to answer certain questions is going to
give information away. Like, if I was going to be autistic about
analyzing this, I feel like I could understand a lot of what's
going on here. I'm doing it in the moment. I I'm not going to
like slow it down and try to figure it out cuz he is clearly
right when he tries to when he tries to be very calculated in
exactly what he'll say. He's actually giving a lot away about
what he's trying to hide. Right. I'm just not going to go down
to that level of autism right now. >> Maybe this will You
know what? Maybe this will clear up. Maybe this will clear up.
Maybe this will clear it up. Okay. Becket never DM'd me any DMs.
There you go.
>> So why did you say you got it via Beckett? I think that
that is a clear lie here. So you were just clearly lying when
you said I got it via Becket. I think my only involvement was
trying to get Beckett to censor Pixie because I thought it was
weird and gross to make that public. So via Beckett. I think
you're you are literally lying here. This is this is an actual
lie. The via Becket part >> did not show you this. Becket
was not your source for this. Correct. >> I said Beckett's
area. Yeah, >> Becket was not
the [__] does >> she should she should absolutely
area. She should grill him on like in DMs. You lied to me and
you understand that that's my line for leaking. So you lied brazantly
here. You made me think it was Becket. It was not. And that is
a lie. And that's what I'm grilling you over. So you can say
Becket's area now, but that wasn't what you said in DMs. You
were clearly lying in DMs. Please, yes or no. Were you clearly
lying in this DM I have on screen right now?
>> She's asked, hold on. She's asked multiple times, "What
is Becket's area? What do you mean by that?" And he'll say, "Next.
Skip, skip, next skip." Becket was not your source. What the
[__] does Becket's area mean? And here you say via
Beckett I think. Saying I think doesn't matter. Saying oh is
lie. Saying oh >> sorry saying I think. It's weird how
it's so easy for you to go oh yeah. Okay. I guess I was wrong
about that. Oh yeah. I guess I was wrong about that. But then
when it's anyone else other than your we head it matters precisely
>> Just wait. Just say you were you lied here. Just say
you lied. The counter presses. Yeah. Oh, people make mistakes.
Are you saying you don't ever make mistakes, Io? Are you saying
you've never made a mistake in your life? It's like, brother,
you haven't admitted a mistake yet. You say you lied there and
then we're good. >> You're saying you're wrong. You You
misremembered. You believed that you had gotten it from Becket.
>> I never believed I got it from Becket. >> you
said via Becket, I think.
>> But which part, dude? The DM on the screen. How is Spoke
so bad at this? This is so funny. He's so slimy. >> It's
so It's so funny. God,
>> the Pixie Kylo DMs.
>> Wait, wait, hold on. Hold on. Shouldn't he have been
asking this? If he gave this answer, you tell me what you meant.
What did you think I meant? You gave me this answer. You can't
ask me what you thought I meant. I asked you a question. You
said, "Yeah, via Becket, I think." What did you get via Beckett
that you were answering like this question this way? Don't Don't
make me say, "Oh, I you got him." >> What do you What does
Beckett's area
>> I've skipped. >> You can't. >> Oh, wait.
I'm not allowed. >> What the hell? Sorry. Sorry. I thought
See, I thought I thought we could set whatever rules we wanted.
Your rule is you can randomly leak DMs even though you're wrong
about someone lying repeatedly. And my rule is I get to skip
whatever the [__] I want. Hold on. This is literally
a lie right here. This is literally a lie. He's basically addressed
that this is a lie.
You will not you will not address the lie. This is the lie. You
will not address it. What is the lie? >> You said that
you got it. You got the Kyla Pixie DMs via Beckett/
>> I never said I got the Kyla Pixie DMs from That's what
we were >> I think I think if Becket is going to go and
leak stuff though, has Becket said who he got the DMs from?
>> Who Who did Becket say he got the DMs from? Because
Becket got the DMs.
Why is Why is Becket involved at all and throwing like a bunch
of heat at Smug Buck?
Has Becket said who he got them from? If it's morally important
that we figure out exactly who leaked these DMs, when why?
>> Has Becket said who he's gotten them from? Becket. Hello.
I'm waiting for somebody watch this in my chat. I know a bunch
of people watched in my chat. Didn't Sunday say he shared with
Sunday? I don't I don't know if he shared with
Yeah, Becket. I need to know. Beckett's like doing this content.
Becket's helping IO press this guy. Why isn't Becket just tell
us where he got the DMs from?
Why is Becket being shifty?
Why is he Why is he burning this guy? Cuz this guy said via Beckett.
It's like, okay, it's like a moral It's morally important we
figure out where this came from. Becket should say who he got
the DMs from. Didn't Sunday say he shared them with Becket? I
don't believe so, but I'm not totally sure. talking about when
we said them. Do I lit I This is so deranged. I I How can anyone
take you seriously?
Come on. >> Yeah. I Okay, hold on. I do. Do you know what
your first clue was? Was me saying we're and you shouldn't take
me seriously and then you're the one. >> Yes, I am a Yes,
I am. Schroing as Okay, I am a total.
You should never have taken me
>> this is so embarrassing. saying that you're doing a
bit and you're lying and stuff like that
>> You have a little puppet. You have a little puppet on
your show. You're a grown man. I'm just a snake puppet. I'm just
Yeah, I'm just a little happening right now. This is insane.
You are riding the line. >> You think absurdity and reality
are completely mutually exclusive? >> I
You don't get to not give a [__] about anything when
it comes to journalistic
journalist. What are you talking about?
I don't know what you're talking about. Or is this for content
or is this for morality? Explain. >> It's not for morality.
It's for it's for you. You don't have any moral character. So
then why do you care? >> I'm not extending moral character
to this because my policy is if you lie to me, I will tell everyone.
That is my lie. You got it wrong. You won't lie to and you started
spreading it. You were lied to. This is all so funny on my head.
If I keep shouting, surely they won't be able to tell that I'm
lying. >> If I'm loud,
>> they're not going to know. >> There's so many
amazing layers to this. >> It's fine. I'll just shout through
it. >> Listen, we we keep going. We keep going.
>> Hold on. Hold on. This is so
>> What did Whiz tell you? What did Whiz tell you? Actually,
do leak those [__] DMs. What did Whiz tell you? What
did he tell you? >> You I will Okay, I will. You said that
you was from Pixie and Kyla via Beckett or Beckett's area. I
don't know what that means and you refused to clarify. So I asked
Beckett about it. He told me that you were lying and now I'm
asking you about this why you said this and you say skip.
>> What am I supposed to do about that?
>> Uh skip probably. I mean the the thing is everything.
This is a lie. This is the only thing I care about. >> Actually,
I think I think what you've realized is that the big things that
you cared about that actually matter, which is that apparently
I was leaking
You don't care. >> It's not about
care about She's broken this man. He just He's just
>> Do you think so? Uh,
>> We'll see. We will see. We will see. Um, guys, if you
don't see somebody in the user list to add them, you need to
refresh the chat and then it will pop up. Sometimes that lags.
Smug bug will really hit his stride in life when he gets old
enough to fain dementia. Okay, dude. He's so exacting with this.
I feel like I I know what's going on here. I feel like based
on his evasions. His evasions were too telling. Okay, I'm not
going to I think probably
I always feel concerned when somebody tells me like, "Hey, there's
a moral reason not to look further into this. Hey, we should
be chill about this. Chill, chill, chill." I think there's always
a good reason to like think about that and consider it.
>> I used to watch Smug a few years ago. This is just his
default mode. Awesome. Awesome. Awesome. Awesome.
>> Okay, I don't know how much more there is here to be
honest. Also, I had to send some DMs, so I wasn't watching the
past like 20 seconds. I need to go back. I'm sorry. We have to
Kelly, you might need to mute for a second because I'm going
to watch this last 20 seconds of him just screaming at her. Okay,
just in case there's information I didn't catch. I'm sorry. I
have to I have to for myself or else I don't know what's going
on. Okay,
>> like I'm like the anti- stardust, okay? I for some crazy
reason I literally just need to understand the content I'm watching.
I feel like a desire to hear and understand most of the facts
presented on a stream, right? I'm like the the opposite of Stardust.
Okay. The exact opposite. She needs to know nothing. She doesn't
care. >> Insulting Stardust. >> You would get it
if you watch, I guess, the content on that, but you didn't. So,
it's it's okay. >> You don't watch Stardust either, do
you? >> I
slow. Was that as a content day? >> I don't think I watch
it on stream. I watch it off stream. Queen watch it on >> You
watch it off stream? That's even
>> I watch Queen's stream. >> I was listening to
Queen's stream while he watched Stardust. Stardust watched my
whole argument with Sunday and another chatter and I don't think
she actually critically engaged with a single thing that me the
chatter Sunday you or Iiko said. I think she essentially just
sat there and talked to her chat while the video played in the
background. She paused when she'd like answer her chat and then
but I don't think she had any critical engagement with what was
being said in the conversation whatsoever. What a queen. >> And
I lost my mind where I'm like dude why are you actually using
my content and not saying anything? It's insane. Speak. Uh yeah,
I don't I literally don't care about Cuffam.
Hold on. I I shouldn't say that. I do >> [__]
bro. >> I do technically have his what the is you doing,
bro? Like cut tape on my soundboard, but other than that, I don't
care about cuff. >> Everything. This is a lie. This is
the only thing I can >> actually I think I think what you've
realized is that the big things that you cared about that actually
matter which is that apparently I was leaking tequilo
what you were saying or what you were saying you don't care it's
not about what
you look like I care about you lying I care about you lying I
care about you [__] lying don't care about you because
you're embarrassed you [__] I care about you lying.
>> You [__] up. You [__] up. >> You're
the one that says
>> Never mind. There was not uh there was not any actual
information there. It was just him yelling, "You up. You up.
You up. You up. You up." I go, >> "You come in. You're
like, I got this. I've got problems in front of you." And now
you're obsessed with something. >> Dude, I think it's a
bit I think it has to be a bit right that he just like runs his
voice ragged like this. It has to be It's just a bit. >> I
answer you. I answer you. Say skip. >> Yeah. Yeah. Obviously,
I'm going to skip some of it. >> Why would you skip some
of it? >> Dude, he's laughing. It's a bit. It's a bit.
Did you hear that? Could you hear that in his voice? He's literally
laughing to himself right now. He is actually laughing to himself
when he answers. Listen. Listen to the laughter in his voice.
I'll turn it up. You can hear it. You can hear him smiling and
>> Yeah. Yeah. Obviously, I'm going to skip some of it.
>> Why would you You can hear it. Obviously, I'm going
to skip some of it. You hear it? You hear it? or he's totally
lost his mind. He's like completely broken as a human being.
One of the two. Not sure which.
Let me turn it back up. There we go. >> Skip some of it.
>> Uh, I have some integrity. That's all. >> You
have integrity. >> I'm going to give it. >> It's
not my job to entertain you. It's not my job to make your life
easier. Okay. Go talk to someone else. DM someone else. If you
give you >> Sure. If that makes you feel better, fine.
Go tell them that I'm a liar.
>> Why? If you don't care, why are we on this? Why are
we doing this?
And so I do it on the record. If it happens, I put it on the
record. >> You're such a hypocrite. I care. This is so
embarrassing. You started I I started off by saying, >> uh,
Spud Gun, you can send me the quote if you want. >> Send
me the time stamp. >> Say, I don't care about this really.
And you were like, how dare you not care? This is so important.
This is so moral. Then I asked you, "Oh, you're moral." You say,
"You say you don't give a [__] about it anymore.
>> I care about >> this is literally just That's
it. That's literally it. >> I'm not tell I'm literally
you just
Do you care when you lie to other people? Io, do you have the
same standard when you lie? >> I call on Becket to explain
where he got the DMs from. Okay,
Becket, you have to explain. Explain to everybody where you got
the DMs from. Okay, I want it on the record. You have to You
kicked this off. Okay, you leaked some DMs. You made some drama.
Becket, I'm calling you out, Becket. You got to come out and
say where you got these DMs. Put it on the record, Becket. Put
it on the record. Explain where you got them from. I need to
know. Thank you. >> Lie about other people. Do you hold
yourself to the same or no? >> What have I lied about?
>> You [__] killed your chat and said that
a lie. That's something that I >> Yes, it was. You literally
spread it as a lie out of nowhere. >> You are here. I'm
saying this to you. But I will say I'm very sorry. I'm very sorry.
I'm very sorry. I'm very sorry. Okay. I retract that. I have
no reason to believe it. >> I appreciate it. >> Okay.
So, I'm sorry. >> But I don't appreciate I don't appreciate
that after one conversation with Becket and Sunday, you're willing
to just spread whatever lies that they think are convenient.
>> This is like um how would you specify this? This is
like some kind of like Smug is like some kind of like caramel
taffy that's like so obnoxiously sweet that once in a while as
a little treat, it's like it's just right. It's like so funny.
It's so good. But like all the time, okay,
all of the time. We couldn't do it all of the time. There's just
no way. There's no way it could be possible.
It would it would be crazy. I can't do it all the time. But Once
in a Wild is a tree. It's very good. If I was watching this a
lot, I would probably lose it. The narrative when the fact is
the story is pretty straightforward. Becca and Sunday both coordinated
together to make a couple of videos about something they shouldn't
have that did unbelievable damage to some vulnerable people and
they're that's it. And now you are doing their sweeping. You
are sweeping up their mess. They're looking for any narrative
that can help them and they're just latching on to anyone that
they've got beef with. This is I don't think I don't think Beckett's
like Sunday's video was harmful because it put a narrative in
that wasn't there, right? that wasn't really something you could
support. I think and just was categorically false.
I think that Beckett's video was like just laying out the facts.
I don't know what criticism people put them in the same bucket.
They really don't belong in wrong. They don't really belong in
the same bucket at all. They don't really belong in the same
bucket at all. Okay. In my opinion, like Sunday's narrative could
be something harmful. It's a narrative that Destiny latched on
to and he's using himself, right? But the uh the Becket video
is one that I can be like, "Okay, if this just existed in a vacuum,
I would understand it. I disagree with it, but like I'm not going
to be like, Becket, you have to be cast off the internet." Sunday's
video rated into Becketts cuz they both knew that they had the
DMs. Yeah, obviously. Violation of consent is in the same bucket.
No. Well, are they the ones that vi So, they did something bad.
I think I would have almost no criticism for Becket if he'd given
Pixie a heads up. That's That's basically my only criticism for
Beckett. I think it's within his rights to say, "Hey, this stuff's
leaked. It's public. It's like pseudo public, right? Semi-public.
It's like there's a group of people who have it. Uh, we're going
to have to make videos on it because other people are going to
release videos. Here's your heads up." If that was said to Pixie,
I would have far less problem with their videos because one of
the biggest issues is Pixie basically had no time, all right,
to prepare her stuff and know that she was going to have to make
a decision right away. She was like blindsided, which seemed
pretty up to me. But other than that, I don't really have a lot
of criticism for them. Or sorry, for Becket, for Becket, for
Becket, Jesus. I think um I think I like understand it. How should
I put it? I don't have like content creator criticism for them.
I have like personal criticism as in like I think you probably
should have been way more involved with Pixie. Just been like,
"Hey,
like I need to know if you're okay with this. I like need to
talk to you about this." I think um I think some of that would
have been important. Yeah, exactly. Crab Navy. Yeah. >> Embarrassing.
Leo, I actually did expect a little bit better from you. I actually
did think you had a little bit of moral character. I didn't think
you were going to do Sunday's dirty work just because you're
buddy buddy with someone who destroyed his own career just to
take one measly failed shot at a pest. Embarrassing. I actually
expected more from you. This is the worst I've ever seen you
involved with. You should look at yourself. You should understand
that you up here. I know you will. I know in a couple days you're
going to walk away and you're going to realize, "Wow, I just
swept for Sunday for no reason." >> Bro, this is not about
Sunday. >> That relationship
is not about Sunday. You just
lying. He told you I literally
he told you not about >> Jesus Christ. I
>> Yeah, this this is kind of Jesus. >> Okay, you're
using your [__] >> I will I will address all
of this if you >> Am I right? address why you believed.
>> IEO, you have you have content. I go, you can't have
this popping up. I go, what's happening? >> It was Becket.
>> Why I believed what was Becket? >> I told you.
You know what I'm talking
>> I actually I actually don't. Can you please like put
the context at the top? So, I'm I'm with you. All right. We've
been We've been on a bunch of >> I told you I got I I'm
pretty sure I told you everything I knew. And what I knew was
that Well, actually, sorry, to be clear, what I thought, right?
Because again, I'm not super involved. This is what I understood
to have happened. I I based on what I saw at the time that all
the videos came out, I got the sense that Sunday tricked someone
into thinking he had more than he had.
>> Maybe the one of the fat guys. I don't know. You you
you people look the same to me. He tricked someone into thinking
he had more than he actually had or no or or that or he thought
that the other guy had more than they had. Someone someone did
a bluff that was successful and then based on that bluff, someone
started pushing the narrative that everyone's got all of this
information and someday used that to basically throw the video
out with no care in the world for the repercussions. And actually,
I think that he was probably just bluffing. He was just looking
for
the information. >> I didn't have again I was not involved
in this. My only involvement is what I told you. So, what about
what you said to Sunday um like on the 16th about um being unwillingly
dragged into the keep? >> No, no, he's not talking about
me. >> What did uh say keep the the the
>> Dude, I'm going to use skip in the future. People ask
me an uncomfortable question. Skip. No. No. Skip. Next. >> Good
luck with me being here. >> Next. Skip. insane girl from
self emulating or something like that.
>> what what DM is this with Sunday? Well, between me and
Sunday here, let me >> Let's see. Do I have to go to that?
Do you have it? >> No, I've got I've got I've actually
I've actually got the DMs here. Yeah, I mean, first of all, I'm
just with him. He's begging to come into a VC because I guess
he thinks we might have something useful and I'm just with him.
And then I said I am against my will on the stop the girl loudly
self- emilating kick. Like I'm just I like I don't know what
you think. >> Yeah. No, his DMs for Sunday are totally
>> I'm just I'm just saying I don't want to be involved
with any of this and I don't care is basically what I'm saying
there. >> Okay. I won't push it. Um cuz >> yeah I
like I'm I just >> I don't know. I wasn't there. I don't
know. I wasn't there. I didn't know about anything until the
video came out. I didn't know there was a video. >> Yeah.
You can ask Sunday. I mean, yeah, like I like I said, whoever
did that, >> I genuinely I genuinely think he'll remember
that conversation better than I
>> but he has also lied already once, so I'm not really
I don't know if you trust >> That me that mess is for other
people. My thing is I don't know why you had to tell me that
you got it. >> We just at the end of this
>> I don't know where they go with this conversation from
here. It's very >> You believe that you got it from Becket?
>> didn't have to tell you anything. I was just trying
to help you out. I was just trying to like give you a little
bit of >> I Here's the thing. Okay, the way that you came
to me, >> the way the way that you came to me, because
again, I if you were telling me, "Hey, I'm doing a story. I'm
going to blow up all of these DMs." Then I would be very careful
and precise about what I'm saying. Even saying you're coming
to me as a friend, I wouldn't care. I I know you wouldn't have.
I know you wouldn't have because you're a piece of But I thought
we were buddies. I thought you were just coming to me. I didn't
like you. I thought we were buddies. You've Okay, hold on. Well,
you've lied. You didn't get You didn't get it from, >> right?
I thought I >> Did you believe you got it from Buddies?
I wouldn't want to be friends with this guy after this anyway.
What an annoying
>> I thought we were buddies. I thought you wanted a little
bit of help. I gave you the vague information I knew. I told
you that it was low confidence information. I told you that we're
a question. I don't care what you think cuz as long as it's about
You didn't have to pause the video for that. Honestly, I just
wanted to sing over the >> Okay. No, I was pausing cuz
it's you talking over. People do want to listen. >> I There's
like drama people are actually invested in. Kelly, I realize
it sucks having to pull it out of this guy spuring like relentlessly
while he >> He hasn't said anything in ages. He just keeps
yelling nothing.
>> Uh,
he is saying things. I understand you. I told you that it was
low confidence information. I told you that we were I know I
know you're not interested or invested, Kelly. I know >> it's
not to do with my interest. It's to do with the fact that he's
been waffling and basically just shouting a few different words
repeatedly for the last 5 minutes, if not longer. >> Trust
me, there's information there. It's fine.
>> What is the information? It's just him saying, "Oh,
I thought you were my friend." That's not information. He's in
the fetal position. Smug is a victim of Ieko's assault. Oh, is
that how you guys are reading this? We'll see.
I just don't know why President Sunday would do all of this.
Why would he try to push to make all of this come out? I don't
know why he would do it to me. I just seem It feels weird. >> That
ginger person's not been around in a long time. If they think
that I should be dressed like a cow.
>> You are 9 months in the past.
I see. Jesus. Kelly just did a good Mama JF impression. Okay.
Is that a hint?
>> Uh, it could be considered a hint. I just think it's
funny that Sunday wants all of this information out in the open.
I think it's just interesting.
>> you don't care. You don't care because it's not useful.
>> Smug is claiming that she tricked him into leaking.
Into leaking what is that later on? cuz it's definitely he hasn't
I don't think he's leaked anything here.
>> Project. I'm not doing a project on it. >> I know.
Don't Don't ban people or time them out.
>> I can time for an hour. They deserve >> One hour.
I'll let it go this one time cuz cow is possibly a little misogynistic.
But that's the one time. >> Project. Isn't this like say
that's not the one time? If other people who aren't ginger are
going to say that then also you'll get timed out.
video on this >> because you're >> How am I running?
I came on. >> You want to say log cow? That's funny or
that's not funny. It's fine. But cow is just rude. Okay. >> Dream
to talk to you. What the are you talking about? >> I'm
literally here. You say you're running. You're running. Hey,
get I get I'm winning. I'm winning. I'm winning. Like this is
this this is how you guys do is really you just stand and go.
You're running.
>> What's up? >> He just said I'm winning. I'm saying
no, you're not. Does anyone in this chat thinks this guy is winning?
>> Um, listen in. >> How is he winning?
>> It's We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. You're running
when someone's standing there talking to you. >> I asked
you in our DMs
>> only because Whiz came into my chat. That's the only
reason I asked you. >> Okay. And And you know what? I I
listen. Okay. Sorry. I'm going to I'm not going to crash out.
And whatever the was said, I don't give a I do not give a single
flying point a while ago.
>> I'm not going to crash out. As if he hasn't been hurt
for the last half an >> Yeah. I don't know. I listen that
is a I think his general personality is crashing out. Like I
think that's literally if he is if he's streaming he's crashing
out, right?
With you or he's with me. He does this on my stream. It's good
content. He does this off stream. Sometimes I get off at him.
Sometimes it's fine. He's a idiot. Okay. He's just going to do
bits. I don't give a [__] >> I just don't know.
I don't know if I believe that there's this uh issue with with
you and Whiz. Like I I think that it could just be a part of
the bit. You claim that everything's a bit. He claims everything's
a bit. You're just like, "Oh, we're a puppet show."
I don't I don't know what to do with that. >> I Okay, I
Who are we fans of?
>> Wait, no, no, no. I He Io did I don't think I honed
into this or honed in on this. totally perfectly. But the lie
is I got it via Becket, I think. And he admitted on this live
stream directly, I know I didn't get it from Becket. And then
he goes, "Well, what is it? What do you mean by this? Did you
did you see them before Sunday's stream?" Well, what did you
mean by by this by them this right? Like it's obvious you know
what you mean.
>> So that is that is the lie. This did you see them before
Sunday's video as in months ago and I wasn't involved. Yeah.
Via Beckett. I think he knows he's just outright lying there
as a outright lie.
>> Don't know. Loner box. >> Yeah. No. No. Absolutely
not. >> Uh, okay. I don't know. >> We're Drake, guys.
Okay. Do you think he was crying on anything else?
>> Dreg. Dreg.
>> Ire. Listen. I think that he's I personally think very
little of Jreg. I think that he just >> uh surprised meta.
>> He just likes meta for meta's sake. That's my personal
opinion. Um, >> yeah. Okay. So, and that's >> Yeah,
Crab Navy. Except he's not talking about a different set of DMs.
That's the problem. He's like explicitly not talking about a
different set of DMs. Is He's absolutely not. He's talking about
the same thing. Everybody knows what he's talking about. Oh,
hold on. I need to shill for the stream. Give me a
Guys, I just noticed the timer. It is once again time to thank
you all for watching, for tuning in tonight. 614 people watching
right now. Thank you everybody who is watching. All right, guys.
I need you to follow me on every platform, okay? Follow me on
Twitter,
Can I go exclamation Twitter? Will that pop up? It won't. God
damn it. So, it's uh I'll put it in the chat. I need you to follow
me on Twitter. I need you to engage. All right. Engage everywhere.
Super awesome. We love watching people engage with everything.
All right.
Follow me on kick. Follow me on Twitch. twitch.tv/jdk with an
underscore. Same as x. All right. Add one for the Twitch follow.
No, thank you. Uh, you need to subscribe. You need to subscribe.
guys. Jo, also join the Discord.
All right. discord.gg/jstlk.
>> Subbox society thing for the five gifted. You're cutting
me off before I get to the part where I say, "Guys, if you really
like the content, you can help monetize the content. You help
it go longer." There's a couple ways you can do that. You can
sub through kick. You can gift subs and kick just like Soapbox
Society did. I love gifted subs. I love individual subs the most,
okay? Because if you sub individually, that gives me recurring
monthly income and that shows you're personally invested in the
channel. I love individual subs. Please sub individually if you
can. All right? But if you just want to give money, you just
want to make the stream go longer, gifted subs, like Soapbox
Society just did are the best way to do it. It's a 955 split.
I get 95% of that income. I really appreciate it. Okay. Over
on Twitch, you can sub with your prime. You can sub directly
on Twitch. Uh, hey, hey, Dance. You're saying you subbed on Twitch.
You need to go enter your message into the Twitch chat because
it's not showing up if you subbed with a prime. you need to go
like enter your little message you were going to do through that.
Okay. And last but not least, guys, oh wait, not even last but
not least, exclamation point Don in the chat can give you the
methods for TTSing into the stream. Okay, so you can get your
message read on stream live. There's the Streamlabs link, $3
minimum. There's the Kickbot link. That's a $2 minimum on Kickbot.
If you go through Kickbot, you have AITS voices, okay? It's the
best way to do it. And every dollar from those donations goes
to more time on the stream. Last but not least, there's a Patreon.
patreon.com/jc.
Not going to do the full shield for this, but there's a Patreon.
Multiple tiers. Sign up here just in case we ever get knocked
off of kick or some other platform. All right, sign up. Make
sure you're part of it. Uh, big time Discord perks, okay? Especially
if you chat in any of the VCs. Hop on the Patreon. I I super
appreciate the support. I appreciate having the support diversified
so I don't lose it all if we were to get banned on kick or something
like for example, guys. Okay, big thanks to Soapbox Society for
the five gifted. I think we are Let me give an update.
We'll say we are four subs away from two more hours on the stream.
Thanks, guys. Thank you for all the support. Really appreciate
it. We're gonna continue on with this content. And then after
this, we'll go through. I think we're going to do a Will Stansel
video.
We'll see. There's Will Stansel video. There's the TechTome video.
I want to save that for tomorrow for reasons yet to be discussed.
But if I if I you know get lots of time today, if we go to like
8 hours, 9 hours, maybe maybe
>> maybe maybe we will do the techone video at the end
of the stream. Awesome sauce, thank you for the five gifted.
Let's that is 2 hours. 2 hours 44
40.
Let's go. Thank you very much. Awesome sauce and Soapbox Society
for helping to fund another hour on the stream. Sorry, two more
hours on the stream. Okay, let's continue with the content. Thank
you guys very much. It is what it is. Okay, look. We get we get
mad at each other for real and that's also good content. Dread
gets sad for real and that's good content. It is what it is.
>> Okay. Well, this is the thing. >> The meta irony
thing is annoying sometimes when you're trying to have conversations
with these people. It could be funny as content, but if you're
trying to actually talk to one of these people, the meta irony
is kind of
>> I don't You can have your bits. I just don't deal with
lies. Okay. All that I have wanted to know. But you know what
when you go to someone and they tell you in seven different ways,
hey, this is just vaguely what I know about what went on. I hope
this can help you. I want to be useful because you're my [__]
friend. I give you You're literally doing what Sunday [__]
did. Honestly, like this is [__] embarrassing.
>> I wanted to be helpful.
How can anyone trust you with anything in the future? Stop telling
lies.
>> If you tell me something that is no you
>> stop repeating Iiko. You Io you have already been wrong
multiple times. No I hold on. You admitted it. So I let me give
you a
handle hypothetical or [__] hypothetical. You're
not going to be able to handle it. It's too many layers for you.
Okay. Forget the hypothetical.
>> You're mad I'm not a Jreg fan. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
I'm that's the that's Yeah, that's the thing I'm most upset about.
Hell, you have already been wrong about multiple components of
this story, which means it was easily possible for you to be
wrong about me lying. >> It's literally on this DM.
>> This this is the lie. I think the the accusation was
that Smug Bug was saying he didn't have the DMs at all. I don't
see that as anything he said. So, that was the original thing
that she leaked for him lying on. And then she was able to prove
a different lie in the DMs. But, I think that was not the original
lie she was trying to point out from him. I think the original
lie was people are saying Smug Bug had the DMs first and that
he was lying about having them. He absolutely didn't lie about
having them. He never claimed not to have them. Right. So >> Oh,
and every time I ask you, >> you literally you literally
you literally leaked DMs based on multiple wrong convictions
>> because of a lie. And you >> No, no, hold on.
I would have to go back and check for sure, but I do believe
the lie she thinks happened here is that Smug Bug or sorry that
she predicated all of this on and leaked because of was that
she was saying Smug Bug lied saying he didn't have these DMs.
He didn't say that. So, she did leak based on the wrong premise.
But it seems like now we've identified a lie he told, which is,
"Yeah, I got the DMs from Beckett."
Leaks DMs based on multiple wrong assumptions and bad information.
So, you don't leak you don't leak DMs when people lie. You leak
DMs when it's convenient to your content. I thought we were friends.
You came on a show. I thought we had a good time and you basically
just tried to turn me into a content cycle. >> I have a
neurodyiverent issue with lies. >> You're I I don't bait
me into commenting on your neurody divergence right now. >> It's
an OCD thing. I'm serious. >> Okay. Well, I'm sorry that
this >> Wow. I'm sorry that this OCD episode has affected
our relationship cuz I thought we were buddies and this is very
>> It's a lie. Maybe the OCD isn't the issue. It's just,
you know, I'm a little bit more particular to lying.
>> Doesn't think she's talking about the Sunday Aaron DMs.
Uh, is it clear? No, no, that's not the lie here. Or sorry, that's
not um No, I don't think that's true. Did you see them before
Sunday's video as in months ago? the the thing he asked here
to clarify was, "Oh, you mean like the the video of DMs or whatever."
Or he asked that in another another DM with somebody, either
a DM or that's what I remember is it was like, "Oh, you mean
like the video shown in Sunday's thing, the scroll?" No, I didn't
get that. It's like, bro, no, nobody thinks that's what you mean.
>> The lying is he knows that there's only like one set
of things that people are on him about and he's trying to get
he's trying to get away from it. it. So, sometimes sometimes
the morality matters, sometimes it doesn't matter. Sometimes
it's OCD and that's why you're fixated. Sometimes it's just because
you care a lot about lying. You like your story changes on this
more often than the [__] DMs do. >> All of
these things are are related to each other. They don't just exist
in the >> Yeah, you wanted content, Aiko. Let's be honest.
You just wanted a [__] content. You had nothing to
do today. >> I mean, yeah, I wasn't going to stream right
now. I was going to stream later, but sure. Um, you know what?
>> Oh, good. I'm glad you admit it. Okay, great. Well,
that was easy. I think we're done then. That was easy. Sure.
You just wanted content. That's it. >> I'm glad. Listen,
I wanted to confront you on your No, you can do this. You can
try to manipulate me. You can try to manipulate the chat.
>> You are.
>> You cannot address your lie. You keep saying skip. >> You
literally manipulated me. I am [__] manipulated.
>> How about one more question? >> You asked me You
asked me a bunch of questions. I helped you as fast as I could.
I helped you as best as I [__]
>> You had so little that you linked to.
>> You could have helped me with the truth. I wasn't digging.
>> I gave you all the information I was aware of. >> You
said you got it via Becket.
>> This guy a headache. They want
getting back to a good question. Hold >> You can't skip.
The skip is a lie.
>> put a pin in that. The skip is the lie. All right. TLDDR.
>> The skip is the lie. >> What? The skip is the
lie.
>> When you say skip, that is literally to the lie. >> Unlike
you. Unlike you, I have morals. Unlike you, I have morals. Unlike
you, I have morals. That's it. >> Simple. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Yep. >> That's it. Very simple. Yeah. Yeah. I don't
I don't have to I don't have to >> be very tragic if somebody
told a critical lie here that put Iiko on the wrong track. That
would be very unfortunate for everyone involved.
I'm just pissed off. >> Manipulation and lying thing. Cool.
>> You literally manip Okay, hold on. I This is so funny
when you literally manipulated me into giving you a story you
could use for content. This is so embarrassing. Listen, I have
manipulating. I know you don't have any morals. I know you don't
have any morals. You don't care. I thought we were buddies. You
asked me for my opinion or something. I gave you my opinion.
I said that we were just lying. How is it not an opinion?
Information will be helpful to you. I just wanted to help. >> I
just wanted to help. That's why I was so defensive the whole
time. I literally just wanted to help.
>> I thought you were actually going to do >> I'm
not telling you to pay attention. I don't think anything's coming
out here. I'm just saying that like nothing.
I thought you were actually >> I was literally just asking
about [__]
>> I have zero background info. King Gedra,
>> I have zero background info. I'm just a people observer.
Okay, you guys aren't people observers.
This is sloppiest
>> I mean, I won't deny that this is pretty >> Yeah,
right. Hell. Like, but but I I Okay, when you said that you were
doing your investigation, I genuinely thought you were going
to do something >> I'm not investigating. You literally
came to me. Okay, I guess I'll be able to read out the I'll be
have to read out the DMs then. Okay, fine. Sure. >> Okay.
Yeah, I'll I'll find them, too. >> You You literally You
literally came to me asking me about Whiz,
right? >> Hold on. Let me pull up the the DM load. >> You
sent me some DM and you sent me some screenshot and you said
Whiz said she didn't send them that she's lying. Who is lying?
Smug. Pick one to sacrifice. >> That's literally it. >> You
came to me for help. Yes. You came to me for help. And I tried
to help you with you. It was about you. It's about >> This
is the first interaction we had about this. How is this about
me? >> You came to me asking for help. I gave you all the
information I had and you turned it against me. >> It's
about >> You turned it against me. You manipulated me.
>> You literally manipulated me.
>> This is about you. You are not trying to help me on
the project. This is why I >> I need to see. Does Becket
say explicitly about Smug that he got them from Smug? I need
to I need to actually go and see if he ever says Smug Bug sent
them to him immediately.
>> Never showed them to Smug. Why? So he's saying here
like I never showed them to >> I never showed them to Smug
Bug because there's no no communication between me and Smug Bug.
>> So if he Okay, so
I'm hearing somebody said that Becket sent them to Smug or sorry
that Smug Bug sent them to Becket. Becket says, "I had no communication
with Smug Bug." How did Becket get the DMs? So the only way that
Smoke could say, "Oh, I think >> I think you're full of
literally." >> Wait, I'm Okay, hold on. This is crazy.
This is actually insane. You literally came to me. Okay, you
literally came to me asking for help on a project and now you're
saying actually you're the project. I tricked you. It's my bug.
I tricked you with my DMs. You gave me You gave me my This is
>> You're a manipulator. You're
>> okay. It was not a project. I asked you a question because
Whiz came and said something in my chat. I asked you if he was
lying. >> Whiz is with you. He's trying with you like he
with me. So you don't care. >> It doesn't matter.
He with you and you fell for it,
man. >> You keep trying to insert things. Oh, the You were
trying to help me with a project, huh? And the project was telling
me the truth and you failed. I >> you asked me if Whiz
was lying and I said yes. Yeah, I tried to help you. I tried
to tell you that he was [__] with you. Where did
this I literally said project come from literally this is literally
always lying. I have no idea. He was probably doing a bit. >> I
literally on the >> I don't take that seriously. If you
say that it's a bit that is like you might as well have said
nothing.
It doesn't it just rolls over my head because it means nothing.
You're always doing a bit. >> You're always doing >> I
don't know why she didn't just clarify there. Like, wait, so
are you saying he's really lying or is it just like all
cuz it seems like uh you came She should have clarified there
cuz now he can say whatever he wants. >> And you said which
of these two people is lying and I said Whiz.
>> That's it. That's the story. And then for some reason
you came for me. Why? Because Whiz wasn't responding to your
DMs. Why did you come to me? >> Because I Well, show me
his DMs. What did he tell you? >> I He didn't Wait, hold
on a second. I was because
it was because Do you think that I have a relationship with Whiz
at all? >> I don't know. I don't I don't know your DMs.
Why the I unlike you, I don't leak my DMs to everyone and neither
does Whiz.
I hope. Has he been leaking DMs to you from me? I probably not.
I hope.
>> he hasn't. Okay. All right. Yeah. Sorry. I get that
you live in a world. I get I get that you
leaking DMs. I guess is like a a kind of [__] foreplayer
with you people. I don't know how you >> reproduce commentary
people. >> Well, I thought we were friends. So I I think
probably if you're friends with somebody, you should give them
like a heads up like, "Hey, I think this is a lie and discuss
and discuss it right before you leak."
>> If you No, if you lie to me, then we're not friends
anymore. >> This is some SS officer. Jesus Christ. >> What
if you think we think li >> He just He just calls her a
Nazi for no reason. This guy is nothing but net. Okay, this guy's
nothing but W's all the time.
I trust me, if we watch this more than like we're doing this
one segment, it would get super frustrating, but that's so funny
that he just out of nowhere is just like, "Yeah, well, you're
kind of like actually >> you think lying is like not not
a big
>> I think that if you think someone's lied to you, what
you should do is go to them and go, "Hey, did you lie to me?
What the going on here?" And not turn it into a three-day content
cycle. Like, you never came back to me. I I listen
we >> I look No, no, no. This is You never came to me.
You never I know you're about to run. You never came to me about
this. That's what's fun. I could have cleared this up immediately.
I think if somebody's your friend, you should go to them and
say, "Hey, this lie is going to make me leak DMs with you." So,
you explain it to me or make it make sense or I'm done. I'm pretty
sure that's where you got to go. >> Down. Calm down one
thing at a time. Let me pull it up. >> Messages we had
messages we had. No, you know what? No, no. I bet you didn't
show these. I bet you didn't show these. >> The last messages
we had, I said, >> you said, let's have a look here. Hold
on, cuz this is absolutely I was bitching about weird. The ve
the very last messages I sent you before today were, "Hey, you
could join the pond as our resident drama sloter so you don't
die sad and alone like the other streams. Relinquish your hideous
human flesh and become critter with the rest of us. Then you
will acquire the knowledge you seek." And then you sent me a
emoji. I don't understand. And I said, "I don't know what that
means, but thanks. You too." Like I I thought we were buddies.
I literally thought that you like I mean like we did a show >> You
trying to obfuscate with friendliness with distractions. It's
I hate it. I hate it. I just want you to be honest. That's literally
I got Look then you know what? I guess I guess if I'm being charitable
then maybe you got you mis
I I look you came on our show. I thought you got our vibe. I
thought you understood. I thought you I do and that's why I was
a little suspicious. >> I don't know why he's he's he's
like kind of Aiko's like not bending to his arguments here to
like drop it and so he just keeps like peppering them all out
all over the place. Just like different little things like, "Oh,
you should know that we mess around. We just we're a puppet show
or whatever, right?" Like he's just like he's just like scattershotting
all of the things he said the whole conversation.
of what? Of the fact that I was being friendly with you. You're
saying that I was being friendly as obuscation. I was just being
friendly because I thought we were buddies. I don't know why
that's so hard to believe. You literally came on our show. We
had a good time. We >> did have a good time. >> I
did have a good time. >> Okay. Well Well,
>> you good, Kelly? What? >> This is so It's just
him saying, "I thought we were friends for like the last 20 minutes."
>> That's true. Now it's starting to circle really badly,
but I kind of want to just see if there's anything else here.
Unfortunately, I made the terrible mistake of assuming that that
meant that we were buddies and we had, you know, an okay relationship
in this sphere and then you leaked
nothing and random lies about from like >> So, look, I
am a little bit upset because you this you like it's just >> actually
again
about the lie you say skip.
>> I don't trust you. I'm not going to give you more information
when the little information I gave you, you've been blowing up
everywhere. So, no, I go. Maybe I would talk to you if I trusted
you. But yes, >> skip because you're conniving [__]
>> Very, very convenient. Mhm.
>> Convenient. Yeah. If you someone over, they're not going
to give you any helpful information. No [__] Why
the would I trust you? I'd have to be >> I mean, do you
trust the chat? You trust the people >> that see that seems
weird to me that she's not the clear thing. Smug Bug has said
is there's a moral reason I am not I have morals I have principles
there's a moral reason I can't answer certain questions here
and I think you're a bad person for doing this right so when
when she goes oh well you don't trust me but do you trust chat
it like further reinforces that he is very like he is annoyed
right >> like it's not about a win for him or a loss he
is saying I'm a moral person so I don't want to leak certain
things >> and Io is saying no no well you're owned go ahead
I don't think annoyance is why his brain died for like 20 seconds
before he said skip. He didn't say immediately, I don't want
to tell you things cuz I don't trust you. He went silent like
he was a computer going
>> Yes. But the the implication there was he had said skip
and it did get picked >> He said, "Oh, I said skip already."
>> What? He didn't notice for 20 seconds that no one had
heard.
>> Well, you don't really notice if other people hear.
You think you think that they're being silent >> for that
long? Yes, that guy barely breathes in between every word. Yes,
I think he would have noticed. >> Yeah, that's true. The
silence is excruciating for him, but I think he thinks he's getting
Mr. Gurled and he doesn't want to lose.
>> is being Mr. Gold. He's just like a gossip. Wouldn't
he be saying that? So when you use silence to make somebody else
like clear up the silence. That's something Max did a lot with
people to the detriment of the content sometimes. But also it
look kind of cool sometimes. >> I see. >> No, I'm
talking about when you when basically like you answer a question
in like an awkward way and then you just sit there in silence
with the other person waiting for them to say something, right?
That's like uh it's like the Mr. Girl, >> I guess. So,
but she didn't ask anything else or Kurtish. She just answered
asked a straightforward question that he didn't want to answer.
>> But then he said skip. He So I'm saying he probably
thinks he said skip. He's He's like, "Oh, I already said skip,
right? That it seems like his mic just didn't come through."
>> Uhhuh. Convenient. >> I guess so. >> Anyway,
what? Absolutely not. Why the I trust you. I trust your community
even
>> I I don't know who's in your community actually, but
frankly, there's probably a few few >> He repeats every
word three times. Why would he have only said skip once? >> I
I don't know who's in your community actually. For frankly, there's
probably a few few ponders in your community. See, I wouldn't
be surprised.
>> Spore, I know you're out there >> Couple of ponders.
>> Okay, so you can't tell me why. Okay. Did you believe
>> anything that's I'm not going to tell you anything that's
not in the DMs because every inch I've given you >> that
that is in the the DMs. What are you talking about? >> You
have the DMs to refer to. Enjoy. You see, if you if we actually
if you cared about this, >> the lie is in the
care. I forgot. I forgot you don't care. I forgot you don't care.
I forgot you don't actually care. So, I don't know why I keep
appealing to you giving a You don't care. You're just You're
just looking for
>> All I want. I'm telling you no. In no means no. I'm
not obuscating. I'm telling you. Just continue to spiral into
no. >> What does Becket mean? >> No. You no. >> You
can't even tell me you believed
>> Did you believe what you told me? Did >> He already
answered that, right? He already He already what? Evaded that.
I I already explained how you get through that because he says,
"Well, what did you mean there?" I don't know. I don't know.
Well, he said he didn't he didn't think Becket uh he doesn't
think he got them from Becket. That's what he's saying. I didn't
think I got them from Becket. No, he did just elaborate there.
Yeah, he already elaborated on this. No, I never thought I got
them from Becket. That means he has to be
Just say >> Well, yeah, but Becket He didn't say Becket's
area in the DMs. He said be a Becket in the DMs. >> Tell
me that. Did you believe what you told me? >> I gave you
all the information I had. I've said that already. Did you believe
what you told me? >> I gave you all the information I had.
>> You already said no, I did not believe I got it from
Becket. >> You already said it. >> What you told
me? >> I gave you all the information I had.
>> Yeah. You know what? >> Who Who's going to crash
out first? Kelly Jean or Ieko? Who's going to crash out? And
he keeps saying the same thing. >> It's not really crashing
out. It's like a form of water torture with words. >> Yeah.
Crab Navy. Yes. This is obvious from what >> I'm moving
on from this. I'm not moving on from this. >> Did you believe
>> Did you believe you were telling the truth to me? >> I
gave you all the information I had.
>> That is not a answer. That's a I don't care. The help
was was >> The funny thing is >> he literally answered
this directly already. Like well he didn't answer this quite
directly. He answered the do you believe that Becket gave you
these DMs? He said no. Obviously not. Right. So when he says,
"I got them via Becket," we know he's lying there. So now she's
asking him, "Did you lie there?" And he's going, "I gave you
all the information I have." It's like, "Bro, come on." >> I
wanted a true answer. That's what the help was. And you [__]
answer. >> You asked me for help. I told you I wasn't a
true You said you got certain about one part I was certain about.
I gave you help. And everything else I said, "Hey, look, I don't
really know much about this. I wasn't super involved. I I'm giving
you my
go." That's question. Does Aiko make like proper videos? Like
does she edit anything and put thumbnails and stuff? >> I
don't think she does like edited like video essays. I don't think
so. But I haven't seen. >> Such a shame. I would literally
just yink the hot girls in your area like picture and then just
like slap Becket's face on there and be like, "It's Becket. Are
you so >> I think Yeah, I think these are maybe she's got
some video essay >> opportunities." The videos I see here
are all uh just cuts of her stream VODs. >> she has some
thumbnails there. Like the Destiny and Stranger. >> Oh,
she does. She does do thumbnails. Yeah, she does. She does do
thumbnails for her VODs. >> Is Becket in your area? >> Taking
away.
>> I'm not trying to to judge you on what you knew or who
you got it from or who you sent stuff to. I don't I'm not I'm
not judging you for any of that. Okay. All I want to know >> I
don't give a [__] judgment. I cannot give a very
low opinion of you. I about your judgment. Okay, that does not
concern me. >> Okay, fine. Um, all I want to know is did
you believe
that it was true when you said to me that you got the Kyla Pixie
DMs via >> Everything Everything I DM'd you was in the
moment, me trying to be helpful and giving you all the information
I had. >> [__] That is my little >> forget
who sent you stuff. >> And um >> uh he doesn't. >> What
is this? Like amnesia
pretend. It's so dumb. >> He doesn't. He definitely doesn't.
>> Yeah, but like how is he trying to convince us that
that's possible? Why is he doing that? I don't get it. >> Um
he's not he's not answering, right? He's like explicitly not
answering at >> Well, he hasn't
>> Wait, no, hold on. He actually has said explicitly.
I did not get them from Beckett. And then he said, I am not answering
this question. Like, were you lying here? Which by the way is
like probably more information actually. >> But he's not
explaining the confusion, right? It it's not so much that we
need to know who did send it. It's more so, well, why were you
confused? >> He's not I don't covering for >> Yeah.
Well, I mean, that's obviously the question that would be asked,
but he's he's made it very clear he's not answering any of those
questions. So, well, we'll see. Anyway, >> cover this off
for themselves. I can guarantee it's not another person. >> Just
say what you think. We're not all terminally drama. Nope. You
know what? You would know what a manipulative cut it is, Io.
>> Oh no. >> Oh, that dude. He had all those W's
and then he did that. Don't if you're just going to run, just
be like, don't do that. Don't Don't slur at the other person
on the way out. That's weird, dude. Don't call her a on the way
out like a little [__] Just Just be like, well, I
didn't enjoy this conversation. You suck. Bye. I think I think
double